how much jumping is there in your
training I'm not talking about training
in order to be able to jump higher I'm
talking about actually jumping as the
exercise because I think that if the
answer is not much or none at all then
you need to rectify that
so unfortunately a lot of people
actively avoid jumping in their training
because they think it's going to lead to
injury there's all this impact there's a
risk of spraining your ankle I get it
jumping is a fundamental human movement
a term I've used a fair bit on this
channel recently it's something that you
should be able to do like walking
throwing running if you can't jump then
you're missing out on a basic thing that
every human should be able to do
jumping is something that exists on a
gradient there are small ways you can
jump which we're going to talk about in
a moment to build up to being able to
jump higher and jumping is something
that you can't avoid in your daily life
whether you're jumping down from a car
whether you're jumping down from a
bigger vehicle like a tractor or jumping
out of any other kind of vehicle because
we always have to jump out of vehicles
but also Sports whether you're
interested in martial arts and if you
can't pursue the things you're
interested in because you feel like
you're brittle you're going to twist
something well then that's what training
is for it's for being able to do the
stuff that you want to be able to do I
like to bound up the stairs and I always
feel like the day I stop being able to
bound up the stairs is today I'm going
to start really feeling my age and the
day I'm going to start slowing down now
of course I'm not saying that your 90
year old grandma can or should be doing
box jumps or even smaller jumps this
might be off limits genuinely for some
people but it's still a great goal to
have and something to work towards for
someone like that I'd probably recommend
doing 100 up miners you know just gently
stepping up and down and raising the leg
and then maybe maybe if you get to a a
good level of confidence you could try
some little tiny bounces like you might
do at the start of a workout the same
goes for anyone else who's just feeling
a little bit unconfident about jumping
in a bigger way if you want to just do
some small hops just you know up and
down like this that's a great way to
start it's still going to be useful for
building a little bit of tendon strength
a little bit of rebound and getting you
confident to start leaving the ground
again
the dog just peed on my camera bag so I
think today's shoot is kind of cursed
it's also way too bright and I cannot
get the aperture and the ND filter right
but anyways moving on so when you jump
what this does for you is it strengthens
your tendons and it improves your
ability to absorb shock you can use your
muscles in a more isometric manner to
create tension through the tendons and
then slow down that movement and absorb
it in a healthy way this means that if
you ever have to jump or even if you
fall by accident you're going to be a
little bit more resilient against that
likewise jumping is fantastic for
building bone density it can strengthen
your bones and this makes you less
likely to experience a fracture or a
break and at the same time as you're
getting older it can be a great way to
slow down the process if your bones
becoming more brittle maybe even to slow
down the onset of something like
osteoporosis and at the same time you're
strengthening all your stabilizing
muscles you're learning how to align
your joints so that you're less likely
to twist an ankle or put your hip out or
anything like that in other words the
more you jump the better you get at
jumping so jumping itself is not the
problem the problem is doing a massive
jump when you had no training to prepare
for it which is why a little bit of
jumping in your training can be so
useful and especially if you are
interested in athletic performance
but this is where I have to say I can't
stress enough the importance of finding
jump training that matches your level so
if you are someone who regularly puts
their hip out or twists their ankle or
if you experience a lot of breaks then
don't start doing massive box jumps
instead start with something easy and to
demonstrate that I haven't gone
completely off my rocker and that there
are ways you can gently integrate
jumping into your trading just think
about things like skipping for example
you're doing little jumps here building
up your tendon strength but not in a way
that's going to cause a massive shock
wave through the body you can do this on
grass and I recommend that you start
with small hops make sure you've got
your Technique right because you can
still hurt your ankle skipping in fact
I've done it you want to start on a soft
surface and you want to start out slow
just like anything else
and that brings me to today's sponsor
Crossroad so in case you don't know
Crossroad make extremely high quality
jump ropes Crossroad is genuinely really
different they use a really high quality
proprietary material for the actual rope
at the same time they have these great
spin mechanics that make it really spin
smoothly in your hand what's really cool
about Crossroad those that they also
produce weighted ropes and you can
choose the weight you want to fit the
goals that you have so for example you
can go for something lighter and faster
if you want to really work on your
footwork or something a bit heavier if
you want to turn this into more of a
full body workout at the same time the
slightly heavier rope is really great
because it slows down the motion
slightly allowing someone like me to
start to learn the skills a bit easier
because you're not going to whip the
back of your neck as much and you have a
slightly more time to react cross hope
now also has its amp line of handles and
these are basically smart handles that
will count your reps but also sync up to
an app which allows you to complete
challenges and to follow along different
workouts to track your progress and when
it comes to gamification and keeping you
cognitively engaged in the training
really makes a massive difference the
good news is the crossroad has a 60-day
trial period period so if you're unsure
you can order a pair try them for as
long as you want for 60 days and if
you're not satisfied send them back and
you get your money back no questions
asked bioneer viewers can also get a
discount of 15 by using the link down
below and then using the code bioneer at
checkout try them out if you're
interested I think that crosstrick make
really great quality products and yeah
thanks again to CrossFit for sponsoring
this and now on with the show
of course one of the absolute simplest
ways to practice jumping in your
training is with jump squats these can
be as high or as low as you want
squatting is a great exercise for
strengthening the glutes and what is the
purpose of the glutes well they're often
referred to as the anti-gravity muscles
their purpose is propulsion to help you
jump and run so if you're jumping then
you're using them for their intended
function this is a great way to train
your legs big heavy squats are actually
a great way to improve your jump height
but so are jump squats and especially
weighted jump squats if you take a
kettlebell or something and jump with
that this will help to make you even
more explosive but again you can build
up to that when you perform a movement
like this make sure you're placing heavy
emphasis on that gentle Landing this is
the perfect opportunity to practice that
and obviously as you start to fatigue
you might notice that your performance
goes down a bit so this is the cue to
stop jumping is something you don't want
to be doing very very tired because it's
really important we don't compromise
form here of course if you're an athlete
looking to improve their jump height
then you do want to train a little bit
differently here you're going to use a
box and you're going to gradually
increase your jump height so you've got
Progressive overload when you do this
you want to make sure you're using a
long rest times and short rep ranges
because you don't want to fatigue the
nervous system the idea here being that
each jump is representative of your max
effort your max jump height so long rest
times ideally 1.5 to 3 times the length
of the set itself but for everyone I
think it's important not to just jump
vertically but to think about the
different directions you can jump if you
want to improve your athleticism your
agility your resilience to injury then
making sure you can land in different
angles from different directions it's
really important whether you're cutting
whether you're jumping over something
sideways to get out the way of something
so I recommend including some kind of
forwards jump and some kind of lateral
jumping as well lateral jumping of
course meaning side to side you can do
this with skater hops which are really
nice gentle movement great for warming
up here you're going to hop to one side
and then just tap the ground behind you
with the other foot and then hop the
other side it's a great one for warming
up it's a great one for doing a little
bit of gentle cardio but most
importantly it helps you to improve
movement in that frontal plane if you
want to level this up and you're feeling
confident then you can try lateral hops
over something this is a great option
but just like I say ease into it jumping
forwards meanwhile is also something
that we need to do a lot in real life in
fact I'd argue you jump forwards and
over something possibly more often than
you jump up and straight up onto
something so for example jumping over a
river or hurdling something one great
exercise for this is the broad jump just
jump forwards as far as you can you can
even progressively overload this and
monitor your progress by laying out
something a set distance and then
increasing that distance over time again
you want to focus on your Landing you
want to make sure you're not pushing
yourself too far too fast this is going
to train your quads a little bit more as
you're angled slightly more forwards I
also just like to do squat jumps but
traveling forwards or even going around
and around something this is just a more
fun way to perform squat jumps and it's
a great way to get a burn in your legs
foreign
ly I do recommend doing some kind of
jumping off of one leg whether that's a
single leg jump squat or whether it's
something like a pistol jump squat which
is a lot harder you can also use
something called Bounce when you're
basically running but as you run your
launching forwards as much as possible I
think this is more something for those
people who are already confident with
their jumping ability want to improve
athletic performance but consider that
very often when you're jumping you do
jump off of one leg rather than both
it's also really good to practice
jumping off of both legs so that you're
not limited in terms of how you can
launch and how you can land
again I really don't advise that to
anyone who's not confident on their feet
not comfortable with jumping but if
you're at the point where you want to
start leveling up your athleticism then
yes single leg jumping is another really
good tool otherwise just start out with
single leg exercises like you're while
getting split squats Etc
anyway guys that brings us here to
bista's strange fake Stonehenge which I
have no idea why this thing exists seems
like as good a point as any to finish up
thanks so much for watching this one
guys let me know in the comments down
below whether jumping is a part of your
training whether you're going to make it
a part of your training right now if you
want a complete training program that
includes things like jumping as well as
a whole bunch of other exercises
designed to improve athleticism and
Agility even things like Mobility
reflexes cognitive processes then check
out my ebook and training program super
functional training 2.0 Link in the
description down below that comes with
over two hours of instructional video
and an 85 Plus page ebook either way
guys thank you so much for watching this
one thanks again to crossrate for
sponsoring it and bye for now
thank you